لم يكتب للثوره الليبيه ان تحقق اهدافها
بعد كل هذه السنوات من انطلاقها في
2011 فمنذ ذلك وقت اعترضت طريقها تعقيدات
ودسائس ومؤامرات ادخلتها في صراعات ادمت
الليبيين واثقل التهم بمصائب جمه مسار لم
تغب عنه دول عربيه تتقدمها الامارات
بانواع من التدخل الذي انحازت فيه لمعسكر
اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ليس فقط
بالموقف السياسي وانما بمدد عسكري استقر
قصفا وغارات على رؤوس المدنيين بليبيا ذلك
ما وثقه تقرير لخبراء اممي تابعين ل مجلس
الامن كشف دور ابو ظبي في سفك دماء
الليبيين ومصادره حرياتهم وقطع الطريق على
اي حل سلمي ينهي معاناتهم التقرير التالي
ثم نبدا
النقاش يؤكد تقرير الخبراء الدوليين
المعني بالشان الليبي في مجلس الامن
الدولي نقلا عن مصادر عليمه يؤكد ان
استمرار امداد فريق خليفه حفتر بالسلاح
مشروط بالتزامه الكامل بما سمته المصادر
بالتطلع الوطنيه للجيش
الليبي تطلعات تدافع عنها مصر الجاره التي
قصفت الاراضي الليبيه بنيران طائراتها
بحجه مكافحه الارهاب هذه الحجه التي
لطالما ساقتها انظمه ما قبل الثورات
العربيه لتبرير القمع وتكميم الافواه
وبالنظر الى ان مصر والامارات العربيه
المتحده الداعمتان للواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر تتدخل في شؤون ليبيا من خلال تحديد
تطلعات السياسيه وتقرير محدداتها فمن شان
ذلك ان يفقد العمليه السياسيه التي ترعاها
الامم المتحده معناها كما ان ممارسات قوات
حفطر اصبحت تطبق على الحياه المدنيه وتكم
الافواه وهي تقوم بممارسات تبعد كل البعد
عن مبادئ ثوره السابع عشر من فبراير
وتطلعاتها فتقرير فريق الخبراء الدوليين
اعتبر تعين مجلس النواب حاكما عسكريا
لمنطقه درنا بن جواد
احد التطورات السياسيه الكبرى التي حدثت
في ليبيا وهو ما ادى وفق التقدير الى
تعيين افراد عسكريين محل رؤساء البلديات
المدنيين وادى ايضا وفق التقرير الدولي
الى فرض وضع قيود كبيره على الحريات
العامه في شرق ليبيا من خلال اجراءات منها
على سبيل المثال حظر التظاهر دون اذن خطي
من الحاكم
العسكري كما قال التقرير الدولي ان ما
يسمى بالجيش الوطني الليبي احتجز او خوف
عشرات من الناشطين واعضاء مجلس النواب
والعاملين في قطاعي العداله والامن في
المنطقه الممتده من طبرق الى بن جواد بهدف
تكميم افواه المعارضين السياسيين كتيبه
التوحيد كما را التقرير الدولي ان صعود
نفوذ السلفيين وتطبيق ما يسمى الجيش
الوطني الليبي الحكم العسكري ادى الى
تعزيز القيود على المجتمع وقد رصد الخبراء
الدوليون التابعون لمجلس الامن الدولي
رصدوا تصاعد تاثير شيوخ التيار المدخلي في
شرق ليبيا على مؤسسات الدوله واشار في هذا
السياق الى قيام الشيخ السعودي اسامه
العتيبي باختيار رئيس مكتب اوقاف المرج
مسعود الناظوري لتدريس المذهب السلفي
المدخلي وهو الاختيار الذي اقره ربيع
المدخلي احد العلماء السلفيين السعوديين
البارزين وقد تؤكد الفقره الوارده في
التقرير الدولي التي ابرزت اعتراف قاده في
جيش حفتر بسماحه لمقاتلي تنظيم الدوله
بالفرار من بنغازي اكثر من مره تؤكد ظن
بعض المراقبين بان حفتر يتبع اسلوب الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي الذي اختزل كل
الحياه السياسيه في بلاده في شعار مكافحه
الارهاب وينضم الينا من طرابلس المحلل
السياسي محمود اسماعيل ومن لندن الخبير في
الشان الليبي ماتيا توالد ابدا معك سيد
محمود من طرابلس هذا التقرير منذ صدوره
وهو يتفاعل ان كان داخل ليبيا او خارجها
لكن هل تعتقد انه كشف عن كل شيء بخصوص
التدخل الاماراتي في الشان
الليبي بكل تاكيد انه لا شك ان ان هذه
التدخلات المرفوضه والمرفوض بالمطلق في
الشان الليبي لم يكشف عن كل شيء كشف فقط
عن النزر اليسير بدل العيان واضحا ان
التدخلات والايدي العابت التي تريد ان
تدعم الثوره المضاده وان تحاول قدر
الامكان ارجاع الماضي وان تفسد هذه الثوره
وان تحاول ايضا اذكاء نار الفتنه ما بين
الليبيين كل ذلك كان اشكاليه بل كان هم
الاول للامارات العربيه وهم ايضا مصر ليس
مصر كدوله وليست الامارات كدوله وانما
كنظام يحاول قدر الامكان العبت بالليبيين
والعبث بمقدراته بل وصلت الامور الى
عمليات قصف بطيرانه الذي وصل الى طرابلس
في قصف متكر
مرات ومرات ووصل ايضا الى مدينه درنا كل
ذلك حقيقه شكل مزعج وهي مخالفه قانونيه
ازعج الليبيين وازعج الجميع لا شك انه
تدخل سافر وهو مرفوض ما يجب ان يشار اليه
ايضا التدخلات الجانبيه من عمليات التزويد
بالسلاح مرارا وتكرارا هناك دخائل مصريه
واماراتيه واسلحه ترد تباعا من اجل كل ذلك
من اجل ماذا من اجل افساد شعله
الديمقراطيه وافساد ما يتعلق بلحمه الدوله
الليبيه في ان تستقر او تستمر كانت الايدي
العابثه ولا تزال ديدا عمل ما يتعلق بهذه
الدول من اجل ان لا يكون لربيع الثورات
العربيه انتقال ربما خافت من عمليه
انتقالها ومن عمليه وحده ليبيا وان تكون
دوله واحده موحده حفتر كان احد جلودها ولد
في مصر واستمر سيد ماتيا ما ابرز ما [__]
وقفك في هذا التقرير عذرا فقط سيد محمود
دعني انت سريعا الى السيد ماتيا في لندن
ليحدثنا عن ابرز ما استوقفه في هذا
التقرير والذي اعده خبراء تابعون للامم
المتحده نعم هذا التقرير مهم للغايه يتم
نشره كل عام وهو
تقرير يتم اعداده من قبل خبراء مستقلين و
حثين هو ذا مصداقيه عاليه وهنالك اتهامات
خطيره ضد الامارات هذا العام لكن اذا ما
قرانا التقارير من السنوات الماضيه هنالك
اتهامات ضد دول اخرى لذلك هو تقرير متوازن
يوفر
ايضا ادله صوريه لتدخل الاماراتي في ليبيا
والذي يحصل عن طريق قنوات مختلفه التقرير
مثلا يظهر صورا لقاعده اماراتيه في الخديم
وفي شرق ليبيا لذلك فان الاماراتيين
اماراتيون منخرطون بشكل مباشر في ليبيا
التي لا تعد لم تعد حرب الهيه بال حرب
اقليميه ايضا اظهر التقرير صورا
لمروحيات يقوم
بقيادتها الاماراتيين من بيلاروس وبعد ذلك
يتم تسليمها الى جيش حفتر في ليبيا
التقرير ايضا يظهر ادله
لمحاولات
لبيع النفط الليبي بشكل قانوني عن طريق
شركه تقع في الامارات سيد محمود اذا هذا
التقرير يكشف عن امور عديده ومثل ما قاله
سييد ماتيا من لندن هذا التقرير مهم وذا
مصداقيه عاليه كشف عن وجود قاعده عسكريه
اماراتيه في الشرق الليبي وعن مد
الاماراتيين لقوات حفتر بمروحيات قتاليه
طائرات عموديه هجوميه واليات قتاليه كذلك
ما الذي تريده الامارات برايك من
ليبيا لا شك ان ما تريده الامارات هي
محاوله قدر الامكان الا تنجح الثوره
الليبيه مهما كان وكيف كان ربما هناك
مسميات متعدده ولكن الهدف واحد والغرض
واحد جعل ذلك عبتا في كل الدول العربيه
ابتداء من مصر مرورا بليبيا وتونس وغيرها
الايدي العابثه تحاول قدر الامكان الا
يكون للاستقرار نصيبا وان يكون المسيطرون
هم الذين يتجهون اتجاه الامارات العربيه
وهو امر مز مزعج وحقيقه اشكال واشكال كبير
جدا من الناحيه الفعليه واقع ان هناك تدخل
وهذا التدخل ادى الى اشكاليات وادى الى
حروب وادى الى تطاحن وادى الى زياده نار
الفتنه وايضا قامت بتدريب مجموعه كبيره من
العناصر داخل الامارات العربيه وحاولت
ايضا من خلال الايدي العابثه في ان يكون
هناك يد طوله من اجل ذكار فتنه ما بين
المناطق و بين القبائل وايضا في ان لا
يكون هناك تهدئه كثير من الشباب الليبي
مات بسبب طيران الامارات العربيه لا ننسى
ما يتعلق بالغارات التي شنت من قبل
الامارات العربيه والتي كان من ضمنها كان
هناك شهداء على راسهم خالد بغوله وغيره
وغيره هناك اشكاليات يجب ان تعالج من
الدوله الليبيه ابتداء من المجلس الرئاسي
ومن البرلمان ومن الجهات المسؤوله في ان
تقف وقفه جاده في التعامل مع هذا التقرير
بشكل قانوني وان ترفع الامور الى مستوى
يجب ان توقف الايدي العابده الت الرئسي
دعى الى وقف هذا التدخل الاماراتي في
الشان الليبي سيد ماتيا تقرير ذا مصداقيه
مثل ما قلت وكشف عن امور مهمه للغايه لكن
ماذا بعد هذا التقرير ما الذي يمكن للامم
المتحده ان تقوم به لوقف هذه التدخلات
و ربما تجاوز حظر مد السلاح في ليبيا لا
سما وان هذه التدخلات مثل ما يقول
الكثيرون انها تساهم في تاجيج الصراع في
ليبيا ان التقرير يوفر ادله حول الخروقات
خروقات
لحظر لحه من قبل عده دول ليس فقط الامارات
هو يوفر ادله مثلا
لوجود قوات اوروبيه على الارض في ليبيا
لذلك من غير المحتمل
ان الامم المتحده قد تقوم باتخاذ اي
اجراءات على اثر هذا التقرير لكن اعتقد ان
منظمات اخرى والاعتماد على هذه الادله قد
تقوم باجراءات معينه مثلا الاتحاد الا
قام
باصدار عقوبات فرديه ضد بعض الاشخاص فيما
يتعلق بالسياق الليبي وفي توصيت توصيتي
للاتحاد الاوروبي ستكون باصدار عقوبات
فرديه ضد الافراد المسؤولين عن خروقات
لحقوق الانسان والخروقات لحظر بيع الاسئله
الاسلحه وحسب ما تم توثيقه بهذا التقرير
اعتقد خاصه بالنسبه للتجار
ولوس
ما يسمون باللون الابيض الذين سمحوا لتدفق
الاسلحه الى داخل البلاد اعتقد ان هذا
الامر سيخلق فرقا على الارض سيد محمود اذا
ليست فقط الامارات التي تتدخل في الشان
الليبي وهناك جهات عديده مثل ما قال السيد
ماتيا لكن هذا التقرير وبما كشفه من
معلومات
خطيره برايك ماذا بعده في
ليبيا
ماذا بعده هو سؤال مهم ومهم جدا من
الناحيه القانونيه ومن الناحيه ايضا
الادبيه السياسيه واقع ان هناك مسؤوليات
ملقاه على حكومات الامر الواقع وايضا على
المجلس الرئاسي وايضا على البرلمان واقع
ان هناك ليبيا التي يؤكد الجميع واكدوا
انهم يحافظون على استقلالها وضمان عدم
التدخل فيها وايضا الامم المتحده وقرارات
مجلس الامن الجميع يجمع على هذا ولكن
التطبيق العمليه خلاف هذا واقع ان هناك
ايدي عابت تستخدم ايضا بعض الذين ينتمون
الى هذه البلدان اكثر من انتمائهم الى
الوطن وعلى راسهم حفتر وجنرالاته وايضا
بعض الذين يتشدقون والذين يحاولون تسويق
الامور على انها مجرد محاوله لتعريف بعض
المصطلحات التي عجزوا عن تعريفها وقع
لماذا المجلس الرئاسي لكن ربما يكون في ظل
هذه الايدي المرتعشه لا يقوم بال كثير مما
يجب عليه وايضا البرلمان المتشظي والمنقسم
على ذاته وهذه الفوضه السياسيه التي تضرب
اطنابها والتي ينتظر الليبيون حلا لو ترك
الليبيون وامرهم وحالهم فيما بينهم لحل
اشكالهم ولكن الحاليا الاوراق قد زادت
خلطا ما بعد اطلاق سيف القذافي ومحاوله
قدر الامكان في ان يكون ما بين الجنوب
والشرق والغربي محاوله مقاسمه او محاوله
لارجاع الماضي في توب الحاضر من اجل ان
يكون هناك ارجاع لحكم العسكر ليبيا لن
يكون هناك قدره على ارجاعها الى دكتاتوريه
العسكر ولا امكانيه لارجاعها للنظام
السابق مهما صرفت المليارات التي ضخت في
عند هذا الامر ولكن مع هذا وذاك هناك
واجبات قانونيه محليا ودوليا يجب على
وزاره الخارجيه والمجلس وايضا البرلمان ان
يتحملوا مسؤولياتهم التاريخيه والقانونيه
وان يحاولوا قدر الامكان مخاطبين الجهات
الدوليه من الناحيه الفعليه في ان يوقفوا
هذا وان يمنعوا التدخلات السلبيه وان
يمنعوا هذه الدول وايضا ان يعاقبوا هذه
الدول وان يطالبوا بتعويضات على ما سببته
من جرائر من جراء توفير اسلحه واسلحه دمار
طائرات من بيلاروسيا وغيرها من الاسلحه كل
ذلك لا يحتاجه الليبيون انما يحتاجون امنا
وسلاما ويحتاجون ان تبتعد الامارات
وغد في الشان السياسي محمود اسماعيل من
طرابلس الشكر موصول كذلك لض نا من لندن
الخبير في الشان الليبي ماتيا توالد